STEVE: NEVER, EVER EVER AND HE
WILL ALWAYS HAVE THAT BALL.
JILLIAN, THANK YOU.
STEVE: BIG STORY YESTERDAY THE
CDC UPDATED INDOOR MASK GUIDANCE
NOW RECOMMENDING VACCINATED
AMERICANS PUT THE MASK BACK ON,
TOO.
ESPECIALLY IN AREAS WITH HIGH
TRANSMISSION.
AND EVEN ADVISING UNIVERSAL
MASKING EVERYBODY IN THE SCHOOL
NEEDS TO WEAR A MASK EVEN IF
THEY HAVE HAD THE SHOT.
HERE WITH REACTION WE HAVE GOT
FOX NEWS MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR
DR. MARC SIEGEL.
WE HAVE HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER OUT
IN CALIFORNIA.
AUTHOR OF THE UPCOMING BOOK
HOLLOWED OUT JEREMY ADAMS AND
NEW JERSEY MOM OF THREE NELA
HADLEY.
GOOD MORNING TO ALL OF YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING.
STEVE: NEIL START WITH YOU YOU
ARE ON THE FRONTLINES THREE KIDS
GOING BACK TO SCHOOL IN A MONTH,
MONTH AND A HALF.
WHICH WHEN THEY HEARD THEY HAVE
TO WEAR A MASK FROM SUN UP TO
SUNDOWN IN THE SCHOOL BUILDING,
WHAT DID THEY SAY?
>> MY SON'S FIRST REACTION IS
HE'S NOT GOING BACK TO SCHOOL.
MY DAUGHTERS ARE NOT HAPPY AT
ALL.
IT'S SOMETHING WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO DISCUSS.
MY KIDS ARE -- I DON'T WANT TO
SAY A MESS BUT THEY ARE PRETTY
UPSET ABOUT IT.
STEVE: WHAT DO YOU MEAN YOUR SON
IS NOT GOING TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL.
>> SO LAST YEAR HE HAD A SECOND
DEAR INFECTION SKIN INFECTION ON
HIS FACE HE IS LEFT WITH A
COUPLE OF SCARS STILL.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO GO THROUGH
THAT AGAIN.
STEVE: I DON'T BLAME HIM.
>> IT'S VERY PAINFUL EXPERIENCE.
STEVE: ABSOLUTELY.
JEREMY, YOU ARE OUT IN
CALIFORNIA.
BAKERSFIELD, CALIFORNIA.
THEY'RE SAYING THAT, YOU KNOW,
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE TO DO IT
IN CALIFORNIA.
YOU KNOW GOVERNOR NEWSOM IS
GOING TO SAY THAT BUT THE WHOLE
REASON YOU GOT THE SHOT WAS SO
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE TO WEAR THE
MASK AROUND THE KID NOW YOU WILL
HAVE TO WEAR A MASK AROUND THE
KIDS.
>> FINANCE ABSOLUTELY
FRUSTRATING I WILL BE HONEST
WITH YOU.
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER I'M NOT
A DOCTOR OR SCIENTISTS I CAN'T
TELL YOU IF WE NEED TO BE DOING
THIS FROM A SCIENTIFIC
PERSPECTIVE.
TEACHING IN A MASK IS AWFUL.
RIDICULOUSLY HARD ESPECIALLY IF
YOU ARE TRYING TO USE THE
HUMANITY OF THE CLASSROOM.
HUMOR, FACIAL EXPRESSION AND
REACH THE KID.
THESE KIDS NEED TO GET BACK TO A
NORMAL SITUATION.
THE LAST SIX MONTHS HAVE NOT
BEEN GOOD FOR THEM.
THEY WEREN'T DOING PARTICULARLY
GREAT BEFORE WHICH IS WHY I
WROTE THE BOOK HOLLOWED OUT.
ALL THE TEACHERS I TALKED TO
YESTERDAY GOT THE VACCINE
BECAUSE WE NODE KNOW THESE KIDS
NEEDED TO GET BACK TO NORMAL
IT'S DEMORALIZING.
STEVE: ABSOLUTELY.
DR. SIEGEL, YOU KNOW, PARENTS
ARE STRUGGLING TO TRY TO EXPLAIN
TO THEIR KIDS OKAY, THIS IS WHAT
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO DO.
LOOK AT MILA'S STORY SHE HAS
THIS SONS WHO SON WOUND ONE A
FACE INFECTION A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T THINK ABOUT BECAUSE YOU
ARE WEARING IT ALL DAY IT TAKES
ITS TOLL ON FACE AND PSYCHE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, STEVE.
BIG DOWN SIDES TO MASKS THAT
HAVE TO BE FACTORED IN AND THERE
IS THE IDEA OF WHAT KIND OF MASK
ARE YOU WEARING.
IF YOU ARE WEARING AN N-95 WITH
A FORMAL SEAL, THAT WORKS REALLY
WELL.
KIDS ARE NOT GOING TO TOLERATE
THAT THE IDEA IS IT SHOULD NEVER
BE A MANDATE IT MIGHT BE
SOMETHING YOU RECOMMEND IF THERE
IS A LOT OF VIRUS.
BUT THERE ISN'T A LOT OF SPREAD
IN SCHOOLS.
THERE ISN'T A LOT OF SPREAD
AMONG YOUNG CHILDREN.
STAR REPORTER PETER DOOCY, WHEN
HE TALKED TO JEN PSAKI
YESTERDAY, YOU GOT THIS FEELING
OF A CONDESCENDING TONE, DIDN'T
YOU?
WE KNOW AND YOU DON'T.
WE KNOW AND WE'RE GOING TO TELL
WHAT YOU TO DO.
SO THE MISTAKES THE
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING MIXING
MASKING WITH VACCINES.
AS THE HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER JUST
SAID.
YOU KNOW, VACCINES WORK.
MASKS SHOULDN'T BE MENTIONED IN
THE SAME SENTENCE.
STEVE: DR. SIEGEL, SO MANY
PEOPLE ARE HESITANT TO TAKE THE
VACCINE BUT JOE BIDEN SAID YOU
GET THE VACCINE, YOU CAN TAKE
DOWN THE MASK.
NOW, OF COURSE, THAT TURNS OUT
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE THE
SUGGESTION GOING FORWARD.
EVERYBODY IS GOING TO HAVE TO
WEAR A MASK REGARDLESS OF
VACCINATION STATUS.
BUT, ALSO, YOU KNOW, THE FDA HAS
NOT GIVEN FINAL APPROVAL AND
THERE ARE PROBABLY MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS THAT SAID WELL, IF THE
FDA, THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
NOT SAYING IT'S 100 PERCENT
SAFE, WITH FINAL APPROVAL, I'M
NOT GOING TO GET IT.
SO, WHY IS THE GOVERNMENT TAKING
SO LONG?
THIS IS AN ALL HANDS ON DECK
SITUATION.
>> THIS IS UNPRECEDENTED.
AND EVEN THOUGH IT USUALLY TAKES
A LONG TIME, IN THIS CASE MY
OPINION AND I THINK YOURS IS
THEY SHOULD GET OFF THEIR DID
YOU HAVE AND DO IT RIGHT NOW.
AND GET IT APPROVED TO SEND THAT
VOTE OF CONFIDENCE BECAUSE OVER
300 MILLION DOSES HAVE ALREADY
BEEN GIVEN OUT.
IT'S NOT LIKE THEY DON'T HAVE
THE DATA, STEVE.
THEY GOT THE DATA.
THEY HAVE GOT MOVE FAST AND GOT
TO LICENSE THE VACCINE.
THEN YOU WILL SEE A LOT MORE
PEOPLE TAKING IT THAT ARE ON THE
FENCE.
>> I REMEMBER WHEN OUR KIDS WERE
LIVING IN THE HOUSE AND THEY
WERE GETTING READY FOR SCHOOL
RIGHT ABOUT NOW THEY WOULD START
GETTING EXCITED ABOUT SCHOOL.
YOU KNOW, LET'S GO GET SOME NEW
CLOTHES AND GO STAPLES AND ALL
THE SPIRAL NOTEBOOKS AND STUFF
LIKE THIS.
BUT GIVEN THE FACT THAT NOW IT
SOUNDS LIKE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO HAVE THE KIDS WEARING THE
MASKS AGAIN THAT JUST MADE YOUR
JOB TOUGHER GETTING THE KIDS OUT
THE DOOR.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT HAS.
I'M HOPING HE IS GOING TO BE
MASK EXEMPT BECAUSE OF THE
SEVERITY OF HIS SKIN AND HOW BAD
HIS FACE WAS.
LIKE I SAID, THERE IS STILL SOME
SCARRING.
STEVE: MY GOODNESS.
>> I'M HOPING THAT THE DOCTORS
RECOGNIZE THIS AND THEY AGREE
ME.
HOPEFULLY HE WILL BE ABLE TO GO
BACK TO SCHOOL LIKE A NORMAL
KID.
AS FAR AS MY GIRLS GO.
MY OLDER ONE IS GOING IN EIGHTH
GRADE.
SHE SAID, MOM, I DON'T WANT TO
BE HOME SCHOOLED FOR EIGHTH
GRADE.
I DON'T BLAME HER.
AND THEN MY SIXTH GRADER.
THIS IS -- THE SOCIAL ASPECT OF
SCHOOL IS JUST AS IMPORTANT AS
THE EDUCATION.
STEVE: ABSOLUTELY.
JEREMY, YOU ARE OUT IN
CALIFORNIA.
HOW MUCH OF AN IMPACT DO YOU
THINK THE TEACHERS UNIONS HAD IN
CONVINCING THE GOVERNMENT TO SAY
EVERYBODY HAS GOT TO WEAR A
MASK?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I CAN'T SPEAK
TO THE PTA I CAN TELL YOU MOST
OF THE IT TEACHERS I KNOW GOT
VACCINATED FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS.
WE HAVE GOT GET BACK TO A SENSE
OF NORMALCY.
STEVE, I'M A BIT OF A CLASSROOM
ROMANTIC.
I THINK THAT THE MOST CERTAIN
DOOR TO THE AMERICAN DREAM NO
MATTER WHAT YOUR BACKGROUND IS A
HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION, WHICH
MEANS WE NEED OUR TEACHERS TO BE
AT THEIR ABSOLUTE BEST.
THE LAST YEAR OF LEARNING FOR
OUR STUDENTS HAS NOT BEEN
PRETTY.
THEY HAVE BEEN BEHIND ANONYMOUS
ZOOM CALLS, SITTING IN BED, YOU
KNOW, OFTENTIMES TEXTING AS THEY
TAKE CLASSES.
AND WE NEED TO GET BACK TO SOME
NORMALCY FOR SURE.
STEVE: FOR SURE.
DR. SIEGEL EXIT QUESTION.
THIS IS ONLY A RECOMMENDATION.
IT'S GOING TO BE UP TO STATE AND
LOCAL LEADERS WHETHER OR NOT
YOUR LOCALITY ACTUALLY SAYS MASK
UP, EVERYBODY.
RIGHT?
>> RIGHT.
AND THEORETICALLY, IT'S ONLY
SUPPOSED TO BE IN AREAS OF A LOT
OF SPREAD.
BUT KIDS SPREAD MORE COVID
OUTSIDE SCHOOL THAN IN SCHOOL.
AND I ALREADY TOLD YOU THEY
DON'T SPREAD IT MUCH IN SCHOOL.
THE DANGER IS THAT IT IS GOING
TO BE EXTENDED TO AREAS WHERE
THERE IS NOT EVEN ANY VIRUS
AROUND.
STEVE: YOU ARE RIGHT.
THERE IS A LOT GOING ON.
>> TEACHERS HAVE TO GET
VACCINATED.
STEVE: ABSOLUTELY.
EVERYBODY WHO CAN GET VACCINATE